[Music]
so you can play guitar I play the banjo
that's sick that's so that's [__]
awesome thanks so you want to start
recording a video together where yeah I
could actually teach you the basics of
that would be so [__] cool it's so
easy once you get the whole like the
learning curve is so steep but then once
you like conquer the basics it just
unlocks like so much yeah and then by
the time and then by the time you know
you're DJing Winston House
I could be the BB rexa to your Avicii
yeah and that's what's actually going to
happen we need more white people in the
DJ Scene yeah I just I don't want to I'd
like to
continue
living right right you know they call
her BB flopsa why because she flops oh
it's terrible Bibi flopsa what song did
she have what
look up her Spotify she's had every
[__] Club Banger since 29 2009. when
I think of like Festival DJ sets it's
like BB's the vocal or it's Sia or it's
Ava Max or people like Ava Max that's
the one I like I knew I knew you're five
you know she was there where at the Den
after Matt's party
[__] Ava Max is at the band no way
and you were what the [__] yeah and I
was in an Uber home by myself you
weren't an Uber nodding off to sleep
because you're 400 years old oh my God
you could have met pop Legend Ava Max oh
my God
damn it I know I mean I don't even know
what she really looks like I guess
that's her I just like her like she
keeps coming up with my like release
radar and I'm like oh yeah another
Banger another [__] Bob Eva you
really do go to the max yeah I'm not
gonna number three Ava Max have you used
that have you used the AI uh DJ no on
Spotify what the [__] it's they so they
releases AI DJ and it's like you click
on it it's like what's up Cody
it's Xavier and uh I got some bangers
for you today let's take it back to
you've been listening to a lot of like
cool you know EDM from the 2000s so
we're gonna like take it back there for
a little that's actually a feature yeah
does it sound computery or does it sound
cool no it sounds real that's wild it's
just Ryan Seacrest
yeah hold on I'm X and From This Moment
yeah I'm gonna be your own person
got all the good stuff in store for you
today
coming up first here let's get into a
lineup of Music you've been leaning into
heavy these days DJ Khaled on now no
what
what wow
so actually I think there's a ship just
by the windows out the window must be
broken Spotify is you know you gotta
work you guys gotta your code's broken
you got to work on that Chris Brown
let's dig into your favorite musician R
Kelly
[Laughter]
holy [__] you've been listening to a lot
of Chris Brown Kanye West and R Kelly
recently so we made up
holy [__]
[Laughter]
up I'm gonna play some songs you just
keep on listening to this one from James
hype up first okay
wasn't quite survived today huh okay
let's get into some stuff you played a
lot in 2021 play Bad Bunny
I really want like that's what it should
be you should be able to talk to him
sure like Xavier I'm in the mover's a
Bad Bunny come on give me some Bad Bunny
you like cosplaying a radio show or you
can call in and request a song that
would be sick right that'd be really
great that would be I think that would
like scratch a lot like an itch that a
lot of people have yeah and they give
away free tickets imagine an AI podcast
where you can just talk back to it
friends
you're describing having a friend you
know what you're talking about like
exactly it'd be like if you were like it
would be like having a podcast but with
no mics with no mics and no cameras and
they talk back to you they talk back to
you and you have a good time
someone should get on that yeah you
should get on that yeah no [__] book
about open AI maybe invent that
AI kind of like freaks me the [__] out
like it's very cool and my my editor is
very he's like my best friend but he is
so deep into the AI stuff I really can't
talk to him about it yeah
um but he uses it to like write emails
I'm like do this and do that like the
most basic [__] it just makes his life
easier and when chat gpd's down he's
like trying to kill myself yeah and I'm
like type an email yeah why is it so
difficult yeah no I mean like I I not
like I was really interested in it and
like I am still am but now I've kind of
now I've graduated past being just
interested to where I've found a bunch
of like crazy Doomer content from people
that are like AI scientists basically
being like we're past the point of no
return humanity is actually doomed and
like like we're nearing the end because
like there's no reversing this anymore
and AGI will kill all humans 100 well
the minute and that is horrifying it's
horrifying and also the fact that I see
I've seen this everywhere of like it's
coming for creatives jobs first scary
terrifying you're not more scared about
the fact that we're all gonna die no I'm
upset that I won't have a job before I
die that's gonna just like blow
true yeah it's gonna stop not to be able
to like work on thumbnails and titles
anymore kicking around what am I gonna
do I'm gonna be so freaking bored yeah I
I agree it's kind of weird that like AI
is replacing creatives it's weird I saw
this tweet that was like it's crazy that
like 15 years ago you'd have to pay 50
000 for an app to be made but like you
know you could find an electrician
pretty [__] easily sure now the way
everything's trending like 60 of code
right now is written with github's AI
that is absurd thing it's like almost
all like Engineers are being replaced
first
and yet it's going to cost fifty
thousand dollars to have someone pick
something in your house because that's
going to be the thing that's Ultra
desired when everything is like
thumbnails art every every creative
thing and every like trade skill is
being replaced by AI
not trade skills stop making only fans
we need
yeah yeah
like I I agree that it is horrifying and
if you think about it for too long it's
like panic attack Worthy
but what can we do
nothing that's where we're past the
point of no return so I just like
hearing that it doesn't even phase me
because I'm like girl yeah I only got
about 40 years left and I mean there's
also I think there's also like people
thought the world was going to end in
2002 right okay and everything and I
even think like we're in a position
where we're gonna figure out climate
change and that stuff too
okay I think generally people are like
doomers but I think like
I kind of also think that humans figure
it out
that's the indomitable human Spirit core
optimism baby learn about it obsessed
with that what's the um not not Sisyphus
is that his name the one that pushes the
boulder up the hill you into philosophy
uh not really tea I feel like you should
be what you really philosophize sure
every now and then I read I read a Ryan
holiday book he's like a stoic that's
philosophy you're like I read a Ben
Shapiro book yeah yeah that's philosophy
right there about stuff oh yeah those
big [__] eyebrows
go to yeah so read the plight of
Sisyphus it is he is doomed to push this
rock up the hill and he can either feel
really [__] bad for himself that he
has to do that for the rest of Eternity
or he can embrace the absurdity of it
and be happy in that absurdity
I love that and I think that's where we
are we have to find joy and peace in the
absurdity of what it is to be alive
right now yeah
totally fair until we're not anymore
thanks to AI yeah yeah